les enseignants de lycée en zone
prioritaire ont appelé à la grève ce
jeudi 17 novembre à travers la france
ils craignent la disparition du
dispositif il réclame le maintien des
moyens supplémentaires dont il bénéficie
en cause la réforme entamée par le
gouvernement mais qui n'a concerné
jusqu'à aujourd'hui que les écoles et
les collèges attrape les professeurs du
lycée henri matisse que vous voyez ont
rejoint le collectif touche pas à ma zep
80% du personnel de l'établissement
étaient en grève aujourd'hui on écoute
l'un des professeurs et c'est au micro
de camille lambert on manifeste contre
une sortie programmée de notre lycée du
dispositif éducation prioritaire c'est
un dispositif qui nous garantit des
moyens financiers et matériels
plus conséquent que les établissements
classiques voilà c'est bon pour alerter
sur le fait qu'il faut pérenniser la
situation pour atteindre les objectifs
qui lui sont fixés
en termes de réussite et de citoyenneté
parce qu'au delà ce qu'on disait c'est
quel avenir en veut pour nos enfants